dos bombarderos de la Segunda Guerra
Mundial durante una exhibición aérea en
Dallas se estrellaron dejando restos de
las aeronaves esparcidas por el suelo
aún el episodio está siendo investigado
por la administración Federal de
Aviación como lo dijo el alcalde de la
ciudad el número de víctimas aún no está
confirmado pero no se reportaron heridos
espectadores u otras personas en tierra
el campo de escombros se incluye los
terrenos del aeropuerto ejecutivo la
carretera 67 y un centro comercial
cercano los equipos de emergencia
acudieron al lugar donde el Boeing b-17
flying fortress y el Bell p63 King cobra
colisionaron alrededor de la una y
treinta de la tarde de este sábado Hank
codes presidente y director general de
la conmemorative Air Force un grupo
dedicado a la preservación de los
aviones de combate de la Segunda Guerra
Mundial dijo En una conferencia de
prensa que los heridos Fueron atendidos
por los servicios de rescate
están recibiendo asesoramientos
psicológicos no solo las de las personas
activamente involu en el accidente sino
también de las personas de la fuerza
aérea conmemorativa y todas las personas
aquí que han podido ver el accidente y
obviamente con nuestros socorristas
queremos asegurarnos de que también
reciban apoyo Así que es un momento
difícil
el espectáculo aéreo Wings es el
principal donde se muestran aviones
estadounidenses de la Segunda Guerra
Mundial